good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
another chapter in the house impeachment
melodrama
unfolded today about the 18th most
important thing happening in america but
we're in washington it happened and so
we're going to frame it for you
this evening so the drama shifted from
adam schiff's judiciary committee i mean
rather
intel committee to the judiciary
committee which is run by another
democratic member of congress jerry
adler of new york
now last month you'll remember that adam
schiff's approach was to bring down the
president
by bringing in a whole cavalcade of
intel and foreign policy professionals
and having them explain how their
feelings had been hurt by the
bad orange man the president said nasty
things about me
he fired me i wanted to cry make him go
away
it didn't work so jerry nadler tried a
new approach today his strategy was to
treat
impeachment like a faculty meeting at
wesleyan so produce a
long line of academics with impressive
sending credentials
have them condemn the president as a
very bad man
if you weren't paying close attention if
you were standing in line at the
cafeteria and just saw it out of the
corner of your eye
you might have been impressed that was
the idea watch
the evidence reveals a president who
used the powers of his office
to demand that a foreign government
participate in
undermining a competing candidate for
the presidency
if we are to keep faith with our
constitution and with our republic
president trump must be held to account
if congress fails to impeach here
then the impeachment process has lost
all meaning i stand with the
constitution
and i stand with the framers who are
committed to ensure that no one
is above the law on the basis of the
testimony
and the evidence before the house
president trump has
committed impeachable high crimes and
misdemeanors
by corruptly abusing the office of the
presidency
oh yeah that sounds bad and as you just
heard the framers would frown upon it
what would they think specifically well
fortunately jerry nadler asked that
question
and witness noah feldman had an answer
here it was
if washington were here today if he were
joined by madison hamilton and other
framers
what do you believe they would say if
presented with the evidence before us
about president trump's conduct
i believe the framers would identify
president trump's conduct as
exactly the kind of abuse of office high
crime and misdemeanor that they were
worried about
uh-huh madison hamilton washington these
are basically the same people the left
would like to see
dethroned their statues knocked over by
screaming college kids
they must be very bad men so presumably
if even
they think trump is rotten then
impeachment
mandatory of course once you pause and
consider this all for a moment it starts
to look
a little less impressive none of today's
witnesses had any actual
evidence against the president they were
instead giving you their
opinions it was a little bit like
reading the new republic but less
interesting
you probably heard enough impeachment
opinions over thanksgiving
from one of your drunk cousins so why
would we care what these people think
hmm well because of their credentials
supposedly they have exceptional
knowledge and expertise
iq is far higher than yours
all of which enables them to give a fair
and balanced and informed
opinion on how america ought to proceed
but is that real well consider today's
star witness
pam carlin look up her biography online
and you'll see that she's the quote
kenneth and harley montgomery professor
of public interest law at stanford
whoa stand back ladies and gentlemen and
before that
she clerked for a supreme court justice
and there are not one not two
ladies and gentlemen she earned three
separate degrees at yale
she's written several textbooks on
constitutional law
if there's one person in this country
who is impressive
who our system has deemed capable of
making judgments that you don't even
understand
it's this lady this professor pamela
carlin
but think again and this is a sub theme
of the impeachment drama
that we'd like to highlight because
really it's a thing that will endure and
change the country long after trump is
gone
it turns out the more you know about the
people you're supposed to consider
impressive the more you find out they're
not impressive at all
actually they're not very smart they
have no wisdom
their personal lives are a disaster by
the way if they're so wise
why are they so unhappy every one of
them is
and in this specific case they're not
even
unbiased arbiters carlin for example
she's not some apolitical academic
pulled out of cold storage to testify
about what we ought to do
she's an activist she's literally a
political activist who donates
thousands of dollars to the democratic
party watch this
professor carlin you gave two thousand
bucks or you gave a thousand bucks to
elizabeth warren right
i believe so you gave 1200 uh bucks to
barack obama
i have no reason to question that and
you gave 2000 bucks to hillary clinton
that's correct so does donating to
democrats prove that carlin is wrong no
it doesn't actually she proved that
herself
she made it very clear that she was
incapable of clear thinking or wise
judgments
instead she made bizarre claims she
claimed that delaying military aid to
ukraine
was just like cutting off rescue
services to americans after a hurricane
what it's like insane and dumb by the
way
she also engaged in embarrassing
political stunts like ridiculing the
president's teenage son
what what comparisons professor carlin
can we make between
kings that the framers were afraid of
and the president's conduct today the
constitution says there can be no titles
of nobility
so while the president can name his son
baron he can't make him
a baron thank you the founding
yeah i wonder how long they practiced
that one in the mirror it was petty
and dumb not surprising though carlin
has made remarks like this before she
previously suggested that jeff sessions
was
evil why because of the name his parents
gave him what a mediocrity in 2006 well
before the rest of the left
embraced the great awokening carlin was
the head of the game she's already
bashing people
on the basis of their sex skin color and
sexual orientation
watch this we have to seize back
the high ground on patriotism and on
love of our country
because we have more reason than they do
to love america
the rich pampered prodigal sanctimonious
incurious white straight sons of the
powerful
do pretty well everywhere in the world
and they always have
this lady needs a shrink the sons of the
powerful really
you're a law professor at stanford and
you're lecturing other people at how
they're powerful
right this is the legendary scholar
coming down from on high to tell us who
is good and who is evil
please what a mediocrity what a [ __ ]
her fellow witnesses were
almost as embarrassing noah feldman the
quote felix frankfurter professor of law
at harvard law school
told lawmakers that he was skeptical of
impeachment until this past summer
suggesting of course that his
endorsement was more legitimate it's not
political
but it turns out that was a lie it's a
lie how do we know because
all the way back in march of 2017 the
same man noah feldman
suggests that trump should be impeached
because of a tweet he sent accusing
president obama of monitoring trump
tower
yeah that was impeachable he said he
also said that jim comey's memo of his
conversations with trump was
impeachment worthy too he even told
slate.com
please if he's so impressive why is he
writing for slate whatever
but he told slate that the president
doesn't actually have the freedom of
speech and should be impeached simply
for saying things
that noah feldman doesn't like okay the
only witness who didn't embarrass
himself today was georgetown university
law professor jonathan
turley now reporters are describing
shirley as a gop witness implying that
he's a partisan or a right-winger or a
republican even but
he's none of those things turley who has
come on the show quite a bit
know him well is a member of the
democratic party he's on the left
he's advocated legalizing polygamy he
wanted george w
bush tried for war crimes he's not it's
not from the federal society
he doesn't even like trump he didn't
vote for him
but he called an absurdity where he saw
one
i'm not a supporter of president trump
i voted against him my personal views
of president trump are as irrelevant to
my
impeachment testimony as they should be
to your impeachment vote
i get it you're mad
the president's mad my republican
friends are mad my democratic friends
are mad will and the slipshot
impeachment make us
less mad will it only invite an
invitation for the madness to follow
every future administration
that is why this is wrong it's not wrong
because president trump is
right his call was anything but perfect
it's not wrong because the house has no
legitimate reason to investigate
the ukrainian controversy it's not wrong
because we're
in an election year there is no good
time for an impeachment
no it's wrong because this is not how
you impeach an american president
well exactly and that's really all it is
everyone in washington is mad about
something
in a mentally fragile age like this one
everyone requires a nuclear response
donald trump thinks haiti isn't a nice
country he's a racist
he wants to have a border around our
country bigot
he thinks it's suspicious when the
corrupt do-nothing son of the former
vice president gets
millions of dollars from a big company
in one of the world's most corrupt
nations ukraine
you must impeach him washington may be
the most powerful city in america
at the same time it is full of sad
people grasping for things to complain
about that they hope might give meaning
to their dreary lives
this morning one democrat even
complained about the witnesses who were
testifying
not because they were biased or
unqualified or irrelevant not because
they were off track or had bad ideas but
because
they were the wrong color it hurts my
heart mr speaker
to see the judiciary committee
hearing experts on the topic of
impeachment and not one person of color
among the experts
permanent washington thinks it wants
impeachment what they really want what
they definitely need
is psychological help